من البناء في العالم الحقيقي إلى
البناء في العالم الافتراضي ،
أعلن ناشر ألعاب الهاتف المحمول الأردني تاميتام أنه جمع 11 مليون دولار
من التمويل من مطور ألعاب
كرافتون تالبوتون في كوريا الجنوبية يغير
ألعابًا
خاصة للعالم العربي ، فهو
لا يقوم فقط بترجمة النص.
يغير المحتوى أيضًا إذا كنت
ستجعله مناسبًا ثقافيًا
وكذلك فلسفيًا في اللعبة.
تم استبدال
قلب الأسد بقادة مسلمين أسطوريين حسام حموه هو الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة تاميلتون
وينضم إلي الآن هذا أمر رائع عندما
تحدثنا عن هذا لأول مرة وأخبرتني
كيف تفعل ذلك ، دعني أسألك أعني هل
هذا هو مدى التفاصيل في المصطلحات.
الاختلافات الثقافية
التي يجب أن تحصل عليها عندما تترجم
لعبة غربية للشرق الأوسط ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك ريتشارد على
أه  فرصة مذهلة أم التثقيف
أه هو
جانب مهم لإطلاق لعبة بنجاح
في السوق العربية
يعتقد معظم الناس عندما
نخبرهم أننا نقوم
بألعاب ذات صلة ثقافيًا هو أنهم يعتقدون
أننا نترجم فقط من الإنجليزية إلى
العربية والأكثر  من الناس أيضًا لا
يفهمون
أننا مثل أم ضخمة أه مثل السوق العربي
سوق ضخم وفي نفس
الوقت
على الرغم من أننا جميعًا نتحدث العربية ولكن
هناك الكثير من الاختلافات الثقافية
بين كل هذه البلدان أم صحيح.
تحتاج إلى الاحتفاظ بكل
هذه الأشياء في نفس الوقت ولكن أه احترم
الاختلافات الصغيرة بينهما ،
لذلك على سبيل المثال ،
أه لأنك لا تعرف شيئًا ما
من حيث أنك تصنعه
لجميع الشركات المصنعة الكبرى أو كبار
منتجي الألعاب  ما هو
أصعب شيء يمكن ترجمته هو أنه على
سبيل المثال الجنس أو التنوع ، هل
دور المرأة في لعبة ما
هو الشيء الأكثر صعوبة بالنسبة لك.
أن هناك شيئًا معينًا يصعب القيام به ، قمنا بترجمة
الأشياء أو كما نقوم بترجمة الأشياء التي
اعتقدناها في البداية عندما
رأيناها أنها ستكون كارثية إذا
أطلقناها باللغة العربية كما
هي ودهشتنا بالعديد من الأشياء المختلفة
حالات
مثلنا لم نحصل على ردود فعل سلبية
حول الأشياء التي اعتقدنا أنها سلبية للغاية
في منظورنا الأولي
، لأن مثل الألعاب
تعتمد بشكل كبير على تحليلات
البيانات وعلوم البيانات التي ستحتاجها لاختبار
كل
شيء فيها  اللعبة قبل إطلاق
اللعبة مع عدد كبير من اللاعبين
والمستخدمين فقط لمعرفة ما الذي يحفزهم
وما الذي ينقر وما لا يحدث ،
وفي الوقت نفسه ، لا يمكنني تذكر
شيء معين مثل صنعنا مثل
النبيذ الكحولي  أصبح عصير العنب الذي
قطعناه ليصبح رخيصًا ، لقد صنعنا أم
حصاد أه القمح لصنع
الجعة لصنع الخبز ولكن في نفس الوقت
لم تحدث فروقًا كبيرة في
هذه الألعاب ، أود أن أقول إن هذا المجتمع
إدارة y ومثل التحدث إلى
المستخدم أكثر أهمية من ذلك ،
لذا أخيرًا أعني أنه ليس هناك مشكلة
معك ، إن ما تفعله محددًا
جدًا ، فأنت ناجح جدًا وقد
جمعت جرعة جيدة من المال ولكن ليس
هناك دائمًا خطر أن صانعي الألعاب الكبار
سيفعلون ذلك بأنفسهم ،
سيقولون ببساطة لماذا ندفع لهذا
الرجل وشركته يمكننا القيام بذلك
بأنفسنا
تمامًا ، وتحاول الكثير من الشركات
فعل ذلك بنفسها
وتأتي في النهاية  عد للتحدث إلينا
لأنهم سيحتاجون إلى إنفاق مبلغ ضخم
من المال
للتعلم وبدلاً من إنفاقهم كل
ذلك والقيام بكل هذه
الإخفاقات ، سيأتون إلى الأشخاص الذين
جربوا 100 لعبة مختلفة في الماضي الذي جربناه
مثل كل نوع واحد حرفيًا
وأطلقنا ألعابًا هي ألعاب غير رسمية
تستهدف الإناث ،
إنها ألعاب
مخصصة للاعبين المتشددين وقد فشلنا في
العديد من الأوقات
المختلفة ونجحت في بعض الأوقات الأخرى ،
لذا  لقد رأينا ذلك مع اثنين
من المطورين الذين قرروا العمل
معنا بعد
إطلاق هذه الألعاب بمفردهم
وكسبناهم أموالًا أكثر بكثير
مما كانوا سيجنونه بمفردهم ،
لقد لخصت الأمر للتو  لخصنا
ذلك في الجملة الأخيرة ، لقد كسبناهم
الكثير من المال بعد أن عادوا
إلينا جيداً لرؤيتك سيدي ، أتمنى لك
التوفيق.